let us now turn to ukraine where the
government there says russian troops are
preparing for a new series of attacks
civilian areas behind the front lines
are being bombarded repeatedly ukraine's
army says it is slowing down the russian
assault using heavy weapons supplied by
the u.s and other western allies holly
williams reports on the effort to get
civilians out of harm's way
in eastern ukraine the russians are
coming ready three two one left so
evacuation teams are racing to get the
sick and the vulnerable to safety before
it's too late
natalia abramova told us she's already
been forced to move twice as the
fightings got closer
now she and her three sons are fleeing
for their lives with what little they
can carry
we've lost everything she said we have
nowhere to go
later on natalia told us that in may her
husband was killed by the shelling
their town chasivia is in ukraine's rust
belt many people are desperately poor
but they're standing in the way of
vladimir putin's invading army so with a
few bags and their family pets they're
leaving nearly everything behind we're
about 15 miles from the front line here
and many of the people being evacuated
can't physically move themselves
at times we heard shelling in the
distance and two days before our visit
chassis vr took a direct hit
ukraine says 48 people were killed in
this apartment building one official
called it another terrorist attack by
russia
one of the evacuation team is tony
demcha
from albany new york where he used to
work in construction
he told us he originally came here to
fight but believes he's more useful
helping civilians i have the time i have
the money i'm 22 years old i don't have
a kid so i'd rather be over here than be
back in new york
he told us his father was born in
ukraine when it was part of the soviet
union and fled to america as a child you
could get unlucky doing this work
absolutely there's danger everywhere but
i'd rather die
helping these people than
myself in my own bed when i'm 80 years
old going my god i could have done
something but i didn't
at a nearby train station natalia
boarded with her boys and a flood of
other evacuees
russia's invasion has brought
catastrophe to millions of lives
for cbs morning's holly williams chassis
vr ukraine